foreign
[Music]
come on in plenty of seats filter in
um
thank you for coming today my name is
Preston Holmes
I am a product manager focused on duet
I'll be introducing my co-speaker Vijay
Krishnan from touring in a few minutes
and we're here to tell you all about
some of the details in Duet now many of
you probably saw some of this in the
keynote we're going to try to click into
a few more of the interactions and show
you what we have today and available for
you to go try and sign up for preview at
any minute at the blog post and our web
pages have those sign up links
so
again this whole conference you're going
to hear a little bit of repetition about
where we are with AI I think it's
important to recognize that these
products are still being built on
essentially a moving train of innovation
so what you see today in Duet is going
to sort of climb this ladder from 2023
and Beyond right what we have today is
just the beginning
and the other thing I'll point out is
that while at Google there are these
core r d resources we fundamentally have
two different areas where we're exposing
generative AI one to to our large
consumer base and the other is to our
Enterprise and business users and within
that we have the two areas of vertex and
duet and really the way I summarize this
is vertex is a platform you for you all
to be a producer of value using
generative AI in your own products and
services and duet is a place for you to
consume the value of US
spending that time and effort building
look at a sort of typical pitch slide
for vertex and where you can use vertex
today it is really in any Cloud vertical
or industry or any I'm sorry any
business that you can imagine you have
consumers who want to benefit from an
easier or more intelligent experience
and what we've done at Google cloud is
recognize that we are in a business and
that business is cloud services and so
we have customers trying to you know use
and be more effective in Cloud so when
you look at a generative AI solution
it's going to involve
um
be back here
and we've done this because we recognize
that cloud continues to not be very
simple I mean I've personally been in
the public Cloud space about 10 years
and I know that while we continue to
make some things easier we continue to
add more products and more services we
have over 100 in Google Cloud platform
itself and so new people new new
employees at your own companies are
constantly looking at a new set of
challenges to solve on cloud
and so how can we make that easier
and so with dual AI we're really
reimagining the way you interact with
the cloud interfaces we provide you this
includes things like the IDE for
developers or own cloud consoles
specialized data interaction Services
security products Etc
and duet AI today well it covers a
portion of Google Cloud's products and
services really in the fullness of time
would be the entire gcp experience you'd
have duet following along throughout it
and so when you look at any generative
AI solution it's literally sort of built
on a stack of capabilities and that's
what we have done here so we've started
with Google's own research and
development models such as palm2
we are then using some of our high
performance
platform infrastructure in vertex to do
the model tuning and serving
we've then taken our industry
information and informed the model with
additional context of gcp so this
includes things like our documentation
our client libraries our sample code
this is now becoming an expert system
for gcp
in the future our next step is to allow
you to bring your own Enterprise and
organizational fine-tuning to these
models and make it truly your own
specific instance of duet
and then finally The Last Mile matters
the user experience is something we've
put a lot of investment in for duet to
make sure that it's intuitive and easy
to use out of the box this is not
something that you need to be any kind
of an AI expert to take away the value
of duet
so let's go through a couple of these
sort of principles of what we're looking
to build long term first is we try to
infuse the context of what you're
working on directly into the model's
awareness today this is specifically
around the code that you're working on
or perhaps the data tables you're
working with but there is a sort of a
vast amount of additional context we're
going to be able to inform the model of
over time
um this is integrated into the platform
interfaces and experiences this isn't
something that is bolted on or you have
to switch to a different tab to use
we really want to then move to making
this more agent based over time right so
that not only will you be able to kind
of get the expert advice and guidance
and suggestions that you can today but
you can work with duet to make plans of
action to manage and operate your
services more collaboratively and
finally
most uses of cloud involve some longer
Journeys let's say you're going to
migrate a set of services to the cloud
this isn't something you do and sit down
and do in one hour session this is a
journey that you want duet to go with
you along the whole journey
all right so today
today this includes assisted development
assisted operations assisted data
assisted no code development and
assisted security and I'll be walking
through each of these
so let's start with assisted development
and we're going to imagine Sam who's a
developer software engineer at a
commercial website and he's using visual
code he's relatively new to Google Cloud
so he's he's familiar with the
development he wants to achieve but he's
still new to Google
and really we have these two primary
ways in which he can interact with duet
the first is as a pair programmer doing
code completion and code suggestions
directly in line as he's writing code in
his editor and the other is through an
interactive chat component in the IDE
a so
as he's writing code duet will Auto
suggest completions of functions it'll
suggest things like Imports into your
IDE
it will help take comments you might
write in code and turn those into fully
implemented functions
and it's specifically good at knowing
gcp Services right so the accuracy is
even higher when it comes to using our
own apis because of the specialized
tuning we've done
things in languages where the ID doesn't
do it for you such as Auto importing
modules is something that depending on
the language duet can do for you
and lastly this idea of being more
productive as a developer isn't always
about writing the code it's often about
understanding the code base you're being
dropped into on a new project so there
are lots of of projects where the
complexity of the code is the first
developer problem to solve like
understanding what came before you and
so you can now highlight code and ask
duet to explain it to you in plain
English
and we are also releasing as part of our
initial release the ability to do things
that are pure toil for most developers
such as writing unit tests I really
don't know any developer who thinks that
writing unit test is the favorite part
of the job
now one of the things we're doing
throughout generative AI Google is
trying to help provide visibility and
tie back to where we understand the
generative I AI has learned something it
is suggesting for code that means when
there is a specific enough literal match
to a generated snippet we highlight the
original training source and the
licenses associated with that training
data this gives you the sort of
attestation you need to apply your own
decisions about how you're managing
generated code or license management and
lets you go back and double check
whether or not you want to use something
say that we found on a web page or from
a repo that had no license attached to
it
and this gives you sort of a an ability
to trust what code you're using from
generative AI directly in your projects
so to talk a little bit about more about
duet AI assisted development I'm going
to bring Vijay on stage
to talk about his work at touring
[Applause]
wait thank you president
let me first tell you what we do at
tuning so at a tuning we have helped
over a thousand companies and
particularly a hundred large Enterprises
and we help companies in two different
ways one is we help companies with fully
managed software projects and the other
thing we help companies with is
building a remote distributed teams of
privated Developers
so our talent Cloud allows rapid
scaling of high quality teams and the
this is heavily possible as a result of
three factors first we have a really
large planetary pool of software
developers over 2 million software
developers from 100 plus countries in
every possible time zone and Country
imaginable
second we thoroughly test developers in
technical skills in various Tech Stacks
programming skills soft skills and
Leadership skills and so on
and this in turn allows us to build a
very detailed profile of developers it
allows us to build good machine learning
algorithms to um
find the right developer for various
jobs and needless to say because we have
cast such a wide net we we cover every
possible skill stack
industry domain Etc are possible
but that said team building is one is
one part of what of the goal the
ultimate goal of course is to ensure
that we are able to produce a lot of
value for our clients at the lowest
possible costs and that's where duet
comes in
so at during we we constantly aspire to
help our software development teams
produce the maximum value for our
clients and toward this particular end
we we've been doing a mixture of both
built and buy where we have been looking
at the best tools out there in the
market that can help software developer
teams produce more and we've also been
looking closely at various things we
should be building ourselves that the
market is not organically producing
so over here we it was helpful that we
started with the gcp uh workstation
because uh that meant we could
effectively operate within uh
Google's environment uh profit from all
the functionality at our disposal we
um
and uh the result has been that our
developers have loved what they have
seen in terms of
the autocomplete and what it does to
their specific productivity and our
developers have also anecdotally
reported that they love the the chat
interface and what that does for them by
way of their productivity
but that said we we wanted to put a
concrete number on this like we we want
to over time be the place where our
developers are producing more and more
value per unit uh time and that's why we
subjected this to a more specific
measurement
so we uh so we run an experiment with
the duet and this is one of the few
experiments uh that we cite here but
all our different experiments have more
or less yielded similar results where we
directly measured pull request mergers
and saw a 33 increase in
as a result of a dueter Ai and our
experiments are also fairly
representative because we have a team of
software developers that do various
different things we have I mean we have
people doing front-end back-end uh
mobile app development data scientists
machine learning Engineers everything so
this is a nicely representative pool of
uh of software developers and
tells us what a duet can do
one more thing for which we we see some
early evidence that we are trying to
better quantify also is the importance
of training and the the additional
productivity lift that comes when
developers fully understand what these
tools can do for them so there's a
certain kind of productivity gain one
might achieve with a typical use like
suppose they were the developers were to
continue coding on a certain day uh the
way they were coding their day before
there's a certain lift one can hope to
achieve through uh but obviously changes
in coding Behavior like writing a more
detailed comment and allowing the tool
to generate more code for you or using
the chat functionality more uh widely
all these things are behavioral changes
that could lead to even larger gains so
we we are also actively engaged in
training our developer pool to um most
effectively leverage these tools
foreign
we we are certainly taking a look at
code base indexing and debugging
um and uh yeah but both of these
we expect will
push us further along toward our goal of
a accelerated delivery as well as our
goal to improve developer search and
recommendation capabilities
back to you Preston
thank you Vijay thanks for your
partnership in in helping us develop
duet it was immensely helpful
so we're going to be continuing to move
pretty quickly here because we've got a
lot more to show about what duet can do
already today in gcp and we're going to
talk now about assisted operations now
Ops as a term I want you to understand
that anyone who's using any product in
the console in this sense is really
somebody who's operating the gcp this
isn't strictly limited to those who
might be in sort of the classic op side
of a devops type definition this is
really something that we think can help
across many uses in our console today
for all gcp products and so the first is
really like understanding
um in a quick and in context way what
our products can do how they are
configured how to use them this is
essentially bringing the vast
information embedded in an entire
documentation into the console and
summarizing just what you need when you
need it and then the other is to help
bring more curated experiences for how
to best
act on certain recommendations or
debugging type situations in the console
so let's go through these pretty quickly
now this is in some ways maybe the
simplest
but AI but it is perhaps more powerful
products where at the time you're trying
to figure something out you realize you
need to answer a question for yourself
that's probably somewhere in the
documentation and so you leave the
experience where you are setting
something up and you have to go off and
find which page in the documentation has
the answer even which section in the
documentation page has the answer and
maybe it's actually spread across
several different pages so with duet AI
you can simply ask your question and
plain English and we will summarize and
give you in some bullet point form
exactly what it is you need to know what
you maybe need to do and that is an
incredible Time Saver
um the other is that we have right in
our console an interactive cln and CLI
environment called Cloud shell and what
can suggest to you certain actions or
commands to perform in that shell
environment while still retaining
whatever contacts you have in the rest
of the console
the other is that
look across things like a given log
entry help you understand what is
happening from a given set of error
texts so we have the ability to look at
log line explanations
you can do further investigation and
because the duet model is not simply
based only on gcp knowledge but it is
based on a general purpose large
language model you can extend this into
other errors such as you know tell me
something about an HTTP error code tell
me about something around even a
third-party product where might be
you're integrating or sending data from
for example here if I'm looking at error
codes in this case I have a recurring
error with something wrong with my use
of the twilio API right and so here I'm
getting suggestion of how to potentially
fix that error that I'm seeing in my
cloud error reporting screen
let's look at assisted data now I'll
tell you something I've I've been a you
know a technical practitioner in various
times in my rolling cloud and I'm still
not very good at SQL I can sort of like
eek around with it
um so I'm personally very excited about
this feature right so as a as a data
analyst maybe a junior data analyst or
maybe somebody new to a certain sort of
data set
how can I have duet help accelerate my
sort of time to the task that I'm trying
to achieve in something like bigquery
and so here I'm going to mention that
we're providing direct contacts the
context we're really making available is
what data sets are you working with
which ones are available and what schema
column names and data types are in those
tables
which means that when I'm asking duet to
sort of suggest a completion for me for
SQL it's doing so in a syntax accurate
way that knows about my data and so
again it's having that same type of IDE
like
ahead Auto suggestion for you directly
in the bigquery console
now it can also use natural language so
I I may not know I for example I might
know what types of business entities are
in my data set but I'm not sure exactly
which tables or which columns those are
in I'm trusting that the column names
probably are similar enough to what I'm
looking for so the ability to write in
plain English what type of query I'm
looking for and have it just simply
generate whole cloth the SQL I need to
find that information is something
that's incredibly useful for somebody
who maybe is not working with that
particular data set day in and day out
and I can use iteration in the sense of
continuing to evolve that query and
refine it over time and that's really
that how we think about duet as a
collaborator this isn't simply going to
do the final job for you it's helping
you achieve the job even faster
and last lastly if I'm working with a
team and somebody else you can save
queries and reuse them in bigquery so if
I'm using a shared project where
somebody else has written a query and I
don't quite know how to understand what
that query is doing I can ask duet to
explain that to me in plain English and
so this idea of working with natural
language and SQL back and forth is
something that makes duet AI for data
practitioners incredibly powerful
all right let's talk briefly about the
no code experience now I understand many
of you may be primarily gcp platform
users but with app sheet we have a lot
of opportunity for colleagues or even
yourself to work and build sort of
simple Frontline internal business line
applications with a a complete statement
right so like from one statement you can
describe the app this provides the
ability to build the entire app sheet
app including UI and everything you need
in sort of one shot
and so you'll be able to use the prompt
describe what you want achieved knowing
what data is available and it will
generate the app for you and so for for
many applications I think we all
recognize that building from scratch
from code building an HTTP rest API Etc
isn't necessary for for many of the kind
of day-to-day little applications we
need throughout our businesses
and it's really that fast
all right let's talk about security and
again this is not something where we
expect Security Professionals to go away
this is actually for Security
Professionals to be more productive in
their work or to help people who are up
and coming Security Professionals to be
immediately more capable and more being
able to contribute to a greater degree
in their environments
so let's start with
um we're going to go ahead and jump and
start to talk about what Intel does
mandiant have
and so I want to see the latest threat
activity impacting my industry so I'll
check mandian threat intelligence this
is a tool that provides thousands and
thousands of reports that can be looked
through and searched and read each
report is an incredibly detailed
document
but if I'm looking for this apt-43 sort
of threat domain I don't really want to
look through 11 000 search results so I
can use duet to summarize those top
search results and let me understand
really what is this thing about without
having to go dig deep into each of these
reports
so I can see the content recognize what
this is uh what kind of exposure this
might be providing my company to and I
can move on to another tool
yep
uh in chronicle
so in chronicle
um I've gotten some Intel that we have
this this potential crypto mining
exposure and normally to connect the
search and Chronicle I'd have to use a
very uh very verbose uh domain-specific
language called udm Fields there are
many thousands of the kind of syntax
tokens in this security search language
to look for events in chronicle and so
with duet I can use it to
sorry I can use this to basically
construct my Search terms and find those
events more quickly and I can run that
search and surface those events
um
to determine what next steps I want to
take without having to spend as much
time constructing the query
finally once I know what some of the
potential exposure is I can switch to
security Command Center
and see that we actually have some of
the vulnerabilities in this crypto
mining attack surfaced so normally to
understand this I'd have to understand
you know I'd have to open the finding
I'd have to look at the specific details
of the finding in the fields and then
I'd have to check the Json
representation of that vulnerability for
even more finding details but here with
duet I can get a plain English summary
I don't know why I'm getting this but
that tells me essentially what is the
nature of the event you know including
why there's an issue and what I can do
about it
and finally I can look at some of the
um I'm going to move to the graph here
so there's a graph representation of my
cloud resources this is a really rich
drill down tool that I can go through
the graph to find what sub resource
might be involved in this vulnerability
but duet AI generates a summary of what
can be vulnerable
and what I can do about it basically
short circuiting a longer investigative
process for me to kind of drill down
right to where the asset of the resource
I need to manage differently is in that
system
so let's talk about why duet is an
Enterprise ready system and this is
because it is built on the same
principles of
segmenting and isolating your data from
other customer data the way we've built
all gcp products right this is something
you've heard Thomas mention Point Blank
right away in the keynote the data such
as the code context or the data schema
context you're sending to duet models
are never stored or persisted or used by
Google in any sort of additional
training way
we conform to a set of
AI principles in the way we are building
duet so that we put in things like
safety checks and responses meaning we
are bringing some of Google's own AI
principles around hate
Etc and so you cannot use duet for
example to write a script to generate
um
sort of very hateful speech for example
now we'll be allowing people to tune
some of these checks over time but this
is is part of what is built into the
product today
it's kind of a word wall so I might kind
of go past this one but this is really
around how we are going to allow this to
bring you the customized training
respecting these same principles now
though this isn't something we have
today
but this would be the idea that as
you're bringing your organization's own
custom Corpus of code
other information about other data
sources or even operational playbooks
that will all be unique to your
organization and essentially managed
within your own gcp perimeter
environment
through these sort of custom adapter
layers
let's talk a little bit about where
we're going next and again this is
actually sort of
um really just a scratch on the surface
of all the things we have in mind to
bring to duet
so today in the assisted development
we've got as I showed you the code
completion license attribution vs code
jetbrain support is already out
available in um in early preview
the multi-code the multi-turn chat is
available as part of today's preview in
vs code it will be coming soon to
jetbrains
and then later this year we're going to
bring a set of Rich admin controls I'll
explain this once you'll see it in some
of the other areas but this is going to
be how you enable access to certain duet
features for the workforce by role type
or maybe you want to turn on or off
globally access to a certain duet
feature that will all be part of the
admin control system
for the operator today again
it's that small but super valuable
feature of of summarizing the
information you need to know where you
need to know it and again I think this
will persist as being one of duet's most
often used features because it
represents essentially the entirety of
the platforms documentation and usage
for every single Cloud product already
today
uh we'll be looking at more integrated
experiences into the troubleshooting
experience and especially as we bring
the ability to bring greater degrees of
context around what's happening in your
services and applications on the cloud
to duet to help be a co-troubleshooter
to determine root cause type problems
more quickly
and then in the assisted data
exploration we have uh
a lot going on with building models and
using ml in the context of your data
right so this is things like bqml and
being more helpful or informed about how
to collaborate in building the ml with
the ml now this is not the kind of
sci-fi one model building another from
from llm point of view this is really
taking the power of ml in the data
and using duet to help you build those
applications and scenarios more
effectively
across the the
security products we're looking to bring
greater natural language search creation
so if you have a more complex scenario
that you're trying to do research on
that you want to talk to be able to type
into a prompt these tools will allow
that
simpler natural language rule creation
for for ongoing monitoring
and then the ability to find and detect
uh novel vulnerabilities and assured OSS
packages
no Code and low code this will be sort
of rolling out directly in app sheet to
many customers over the next few months
interactive explanations can help
essentially bring apps to to make them
more updatable right now they're sort of
the app creation phase but there isn't
the opportunity to iterate and refine
that application so that ability to
iterate and derive either variants or
improvements on existing applications is
what we're looking for next
all right so preview is available today
you should be able to find what you need
to sign up for that through the blog
post or through our web page we've
actually worked very hard over the last
week to make this very expedited if you
had earlier been part of our trusted
tester program
um you know that we were letting only in
sort of trickles of people at a time so
we hope to be opening this up over time
much more widely so we encourage you all
to sign up
and in in the products themselves but
remember I talked a lot about how we've
built a lot of user experience sort of
polished into duet today that includes
how to get your feedback so we have
things like when you get a SQL generated
sample you can give us an immediate
thumbs up thumbs down did that work or
did that not work you can send us
feedback about code responses and and
we're looking at all of that this is
really going to be an ongoing
collaboration this is an emerging space
we all know that generative AI as it is
today is still relatively new to the
scene we all know that things like
hallucinations and Imperfections and
accuracy are going to be par for the
course but I can tell you watching this
over the last three to six months
this is changing so quickly that this is
something you really want to integrate
into your workflows today and begin to
understand where this is applicable
right now and that way you are best set
up to understand as it evolves how to be
most effective with it as we continue to
build sort of week by week and month by
month improvements
so thank you all for coming
over the next coming weeks thank you
thank you
foreign